veamos si podemos multiplicar 9 por 0.6
y podemos expresar lo como 9 por 0.6
y los invito a qué pausa en el vídeo en
este momento y traten de resolverlo por
ustedes mismos aunque les voy a dar una
pista 0.6 es lo mismo que tener 6
dividido entre 10
si tenemos 6.0 y lo dividimos entre 10
el punto decimal se va a desplazar hacia
la izquierda un lugar de manera que nos
va a quedar 0.6 lo mismo que acá ahora
lo que voy a hacer es usar esto último
para reescribir esta operación 9 por
punto 6 es igual a 9 por 6 entre 10
y podemos hacer primero la división de 6
entre 10 y luego multiplicarlo por 9 que
es como está expresado acá o podemos
hacerlo de esta manera primero hacer
esta multiplicación y el resultado
dividirlo entre 10 vamos a hacer esto de
acá el 9 por 6 es igual a 54 entre 10
esto de aquí también es si lo expreso
como está acá puedo ponerlo como 9 x 6
y esto es igual a 54 como ya lo habíamos
visto 54 ahora para poder tener este
valor que es el que nos preguntan si
tenemos esta notificación ahora el
resultado lo tenemos que dividir entre
10 si esto lo divide entre 10 lo que voy
a hacer es recorrer este punto decimal
un lugar hacia la izquierda me va a
quedar 5.4 así que esto es igual a 5.4
que es lo mismo que tener 9 por punto 6
igual a 5.4 noten y de hecho lo voy a
quitar de aquí que este 9 por 6
el 54 y 9.600 5.4 aquí podemos ver un
patrón voy a reescribir lo aquí para que
lo noten mejor tenemos nuestra operación
original que es 9 x 0.6 y el resultado
de esta fue 5.4 aparte hicimos esta
operación de 9 x 6 y esta en cambio nos
dio 54 la diferencia aquí es que
recorrimos el punto un lugar hacia la
derecha o lo que es lo mismo esta parte
se multiplicó por 10 y para que este
resultado sea el mismo que nos piden de
regreso esto lo tenemos que dividir
entre 10
el patrón que yo les estaba comentando
mencionando es que si tenemos aquí un
número a la derecha del punto decimal
este punto 6
el resultado va a tener también un
número a la derecha del punto decimal
aquí no hay ningún número a la derecha
del punto decimal por lo que nuestro
resultado no tiene un punto decimal por
acá pero aquí sí ese es el patrón que
quiero que noten como un principio
general si contamos todos los números
que estén a la derecha del punto decimal
en las cantidades que vayamos a
multiplicar ese número de números es el
que vamos a tener que en el resultado
recorrer el punto decimal hacia la
izquierda reflexionen sobre esto y nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo